this is the moment before the suspension
bridge with hundreds on it collapsed
plunging most into the matutz river in
the town of morbi in the state of
Gujarat scores have lost their lives
many are children and women
rescue operations continued through the
night and into today with dozens still
feared missing
so far 170 people have been rescued but
the Muddy Waters of the river are making
it difficult for the military teams to
conduct their operations
my friend is dead his name was pharaohs
we were stuck on the bridge unable to
move forward when we were in the middle
of the bridge it suddenly collapsed
awesome Twisted pieces of metal still
remain from this 230 meter Heritage
Bridge
it was packed with families who had come
to celebrate the Hindu festivals of
chattan Diwali
many people were seen clinging onto the
railings of the bridge when it collapsed
survivors were rushed to the nearby
hospitals by ambulances that lined the
river
nine people have been detained by the
police and a criminal case has been
lodged against those in charge of
Maintenance renovation and management of
the bridge
the bridge which was under repair for
six months was reopened without getting
a fitness certificate from the local
Administration
[Music]
[Music]
the injured continued to arrive at
hospitals as panicked families fill the
waiting rooms searching for their loved
ones Neville Lazarus Sky News